[Music]
but everyone here loves a giant nerd so
someone's gotta be sitting there who
wants to get a prime seat you're in the
splash zone for you I'm great I had
avvocato and toast this morning to ask
me why something hard for somebody else
to understand like that's outside my
area of expertise the conference so it's
been a huge success we sold out but we
wish we get to horde view but as you can
see we already have some tight quarters
yeah my students they just make memes
about my classes what is with students
making memes
I don't know but they're like and not
even mind like they're like man did you
see this and there's like a little video
like I've been wearing it's like my
class yeah and so the talk is twenty
minutes of me trying my best to make
this accessible learning you can toggle
and that means things from like just
explaining how deep learning is really a
bunch of linear regressions with the
linear a linear getting tons of pet
photos and putting comics and of the fun
the unofficial like J didn't say this
but the unofficial job that I have at
our studio and others do is to like
these are my words like make our suck
class right so maybe the solution is
just said george RR martin you and tie
you to a desk
and have a CGI dragon breathing down
your neck
fans can put well I don't forget people
are throwing tons of money at ya
everyone speak the audience have a very
fun time
[Applause]
you
[Music]